[Music]
good afternoon I am Barbara Nichols
class of 1994 currently majoring in
material science and engineering from
behalf of president Charles vest the
Planning Committee of the Martin Luther
King celebration in the MIT community I
welcome our distinguished guests
Reverend William H great a third a
native of my hometown Philadelphia and
all of the guests to the nineteenth
annual dr. Martin Luther King jr.
memorial celebration this year's theme
is the title of dr. King's last book
where do we go from here
chaos or community this phrase best
describes the predicament we are faced
with today in the 90s we have witnessed
the fall of affirmative action
the explosion of racial tension in our
community the travesty of justice termed
the Rodney King verdict in the further
decline of our communities the strides
made by the civil rights movement seemed
to be outweighed by the very
infrastructure it had once overcome for
however few who feel the dream is alive
there are dozens more fulfilled the
dream is dead this year's celebration is
not focused on dr. King's dream but
centered upon his ability to empower
people for positive change the
revolution for equality for all people
in his last book he addresses us on how
to promote real change in our society
civil rights legislation is not the end
but it's the beginning for true racial
harmony to exist in our society now we
will open
our ceremony with the invocation given
by Reverend Scott paradise
[Applause]
let us pray O God we need all the grace
and strength and courage you can give us
we also know that you have little
patience with pretence and value above
all those who are true of heart as we
honor your servant Martin Luther King
today may we commit ourselves to the
full range of his message he stood for
full racial justice
he called for a nation where people
would be judged by the quality of their
souls may we honor that dream by our
actions in this community he stood for
economic justice
he called for a nation where none would
need to be without food or shelter or
education or health care or dignity may
we honor that vision in our priorities
he stood for peace and non-violence
he faced bigotry and police violence
with prayer the word of truth and
willingness to suffer he declared this
nation the greatest purveyor of violence
in the world
he lost the support of friends and
allies by insisting the Vietnam War was
wrong may we honor his memory by calling
for non-violence in our national policy
in our streets in our homes and in our
hearts give us the spirit to be serious
about these things the grace to be
genuine
give us the courage to give ourselves to
the cause of racial justice economic
justice and on violence that we may have
community and not chaos amen
at this time the MIT gospel choir will
lead us and lift every voice and sing
you'll find the words to the song
printed on the back of the program
[Music]
[Applause]
there is a slight change in our program
at this time there will be a dance
selection performed by Robin awfully
from the admissions office
well right now we'll just move on in our
program it has been the tradition of the
Martin Luther King celebration to hear
the youth perspective from the life and
legacy of dr. King first we were here
from to Cambridge Rindge and Latin high
school students they are Myesha Simmons
and Adeline Budin
- president vast - our steamed guest
speaker - the other members of today's
program and to you our audience I bid
you a fond good afternoon it is indeed a
privilege and an honor to come before
you to commemorate the life of dr.
Martin Luther King jr. given the theme
of this year's program where do we go
from here
chaos or community I would like to share
with you some of dr. King's thoughts on
this question excerpt from his adjust to
the Southern Christian Leadership
Conference I want to say to you as we
talk about where do we go from here that
we honestly face the fact that the
movement must adjust itself to the
question of restructuring the whole of
the United States there are 40 million
poor people here and one day we must ask
the question why are there 40 million
poor people in America and when you
begin to ask that question you are
raising questions about the economic
system about a broader distribution of
wealth when you ask that question you
begin to question the capitalistic
economy and I'm simply saying that more
and more we've got to begin to ask
questions about the whole society we are
called upon to help the discouraged
beggars and life's marketplace but one
day we must come to cede that an edifice
which produces beggars needs restructure
it means that questions must be raised
you see my friends when you deal with
this you begin to ask the question who
owns the oil you begin to ask the
question who owns the ore you begin to
ask the question why is it that people
have to pay water bills in America in
the world that are two-thirds water
these are questions that must be asked
now when I say question the whole
society it means ultimately coming to
see that the problem of racism the
problem of economic exploitation and the
problem of war are all tied together
these are the triple evils that are
interrelated
a nation that will keep people in
slavery for 244 years will signify them
make them things therefore they will
exploit them and poor people generally
economically a nation that will explain
a konami will have to have foreign
investments and everything else and will
have to use its military might to
protect them all of these problems are
tied together and what i am saying is
that we must go from this convention
saying america you must be born again
let us realize that william cullen
bryant is right truth crushed to the
earth will rise again let us go out
realizing that the bible is right
be not deceived God is not mocked
whatsoever a man soweth that shall he
also reap this is for hope for the
future and with this faith will be able
to sing and not some distant tomorrow
with a cosmic past tense we have
overcome we have overcome deep in my
heart I did believe we would overcome
thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon my name is adilyn Roedean
I'm a student in the MIT Wesley I put
down program and a senior at the
Cambridge Rindge and Latin High School
Martin Luther King Jr Martin Luther King
jr. is my leader and hopefully your
leader he was a man who believed in
something and carried his beliefs to its
fullest extent he was a civil rights
leader he had a dream which he fought
for he did not just sit down and say I
have a dream without doing anything
about it like a lot of us do instead he
fought for the rights of our people he
fought so that not only blacks but all
people would be treated equally because
of the efforts of Martin Luther King jr.
and many other civil rights leaders
black and other people of color are now
allowed to sit anywhere on the buses
drank from the same water fountain
eating the same restaurants and attend
the same schools as white people
Martin Luther King jr. should not be
remembered on January 15 just because of
his birth date
or in February just because of Black
History Month no a man of his stature
should be remembered throughout the year
by everybody we should all work to keep
a piece of Martin Luther King jr. within
us so that his life and beliefs will
inspire us to live better and more
prosperous lives although Martin Luther
King died almost 25 years ago his spirit
is still alive for all of us here today
if we just adopt his beliefs we can
continue his work I say let's start by
stopping discrimination let's stop the
black on black crime let's stop the
hatred and killing
some of us are allowing prejudice and
bigotry to enter into our dealings with
one another while others of us are
saying I love Martin Luther King yet
finding it possible to take another's
life how can we be believers of Martin
Luther King and at the same time
practice that which he was so strongly
against I would like to leave you with
that thought as you reflect upon the
theme of today's program where do we go
from here
chaos or community thank you
next we will hear from two MIT students
there's been another slight change to
the program first my sister Richards
class of 1995 was give her reflections
then Adam Morales class in 1996 will
speak in place of Melissa Gonzalez good
afternoon my name is Masha Richard and
I'm a sophomore here at MIT I would like
to take some time today to reflect on on
today's subject where do we go from here
chaos or community I would like to
advance towards community working with
my neighbors of all races to achieve a
more peaceful world I would also like to
advance the community of my people so
we've continued to be a strong proud
race so you may ask how do I believe we
should achieve this community I believe
that first we must educate ourselves I
had the highest respect for those who
returned to formal education after
severe break those who obtain GEDs after
dropping out of high school or degrees
after establishing a family should be
commended by everyone
the thought of raising a family and
continuing a career and attending night
classes
amazes me even if you don't go to formal
school attend company seminars and
training classes educate yourself with
common sense by paying attention to your
surroundings at work and in the
community pay attention to others
attitudes about you and do not associate
with those that tear you down
secondly we must remember those less
fortunate than ourselves we need to
support one another and not tear each
other down if someone tries to take on
an impossible task don't immediately
dissuade him or her reveal the
disadvantages the person may have
overlooked if he or she understands and
has considered the problems yet finds
the goal obtainable encourage him or her
the results may be surprising and if not
support the person when your help or
sympathy is needed take time to listen
to each other don't become so wrapped up
in academics or your career that you
don't stop for a friendly conversation
for nothing is more refreshing than
interaction with fellow man thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon my name is Adam Morales
and I'm a freshman here at MIT I would
like to open with an excerpt from a
tribute to Martin Luther King jr.
written by Harry Belafonte and Stanley
Levison in a nation tenaciously racist a
black man sensitized its summerlin
conscience a nation sick with violence a
black man preached non-violence a nation
corrosive with alienation a black man
preached love in a world embroiled in
three wars in 20 years
a black man preached peace when an
assassin's bullet and in martin luther
king's life it failed in its purpose
more people heard his message in four
days than in the 12 years of his
preaching his voice was still but his
message rang clamorously around the
globe Martin Luther King's message was
meant not just for blacks but for all
suppressed people his words affected my
life greatly as a young Porter ikan
growing up in Brooklyn I have faced
discrimination in many forms I've had
teachers accuse me of cheating on tests
because there was no way possibly of me
doing that well my own classmates have
asked me before if if I've ever been in
jail and men have kept their distance
even when I was accepted to MIT many
told me it was just because I was Puerto
Rican Martin Luther King had a dream a
dream in which all people regardless of
color or nationality would be equal and
at peace with each other I've grown up
believing in history I've worked hard to
overcome the stereotypes placed on
Puerto Ricans I'm sure that I'm just as
smart as anyone else and deserve to be
treated equally not unfairly I still
look forward to the day when I can be
recognized for who I am and what I've
done I can't predict the future but I
know how I will approach it
I work toward the dream of Martin Luther
King a dream where all people can come
together in the community not separated
by our differences but brought together
by our similarities thank you
now we will see a dance selection
performed by members of the MIT dance
troop movements in time
if I can just make it
[Music]
Kanwar
ooh that see
[Music]
they're probably
Pierre thousand D sound to tell
[Music]
I'll just begin
I'll say thanks
you ask why
this will be my reply should know
[Music]
make it
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you see
persecution
[Music]
[Applause]
now president vest will give us his
opening remarks and introduce our
keynote speaker
Thank You Barbara on behalf of MIT it is
my great pleasure to welcome all of you
to this assembly in honor of and in
celebration of the life of dr. Martin
Luther King jr. before we begin the
formal part of the program I would like
to take a moment to honor another person
who has made a great difference to the
life of MIT and to working men and women
throughout the country I refer to our
colleague professor emeritus Phyllis a
Wallis who died earlier this week a
member of the Sloan School faculty
professor Wallace was a labor economist
who pioneered in the study of racial and
sexual discrimination in the workplace
in the early 1970s she directed studies
for a landmark federal lawsuit on
discrimination that had far-reaching
consequences for the wages and working
conditions of women and minorities
nationally it was our good fortune when
she joined the MIT faculty in 1975
bringing these same interests and
expertise into the research programs and
curricula of the Sloan School even after
her retirement she continued to serve
MIT in significant ways and recently had
begun to work with Dean Lester Thurow on
special projects that required Phyllis's
wisdom diplomacy and effectiveness and
it was my own good fortune to meet
professor Wallace as a member of the
presidential search committee that
brought me to the Institute
I had the even greater privilege
thereafter of calling on her wise advice
on how to move mi t--'s diversity agenda
forward we will all miss her greatly
this morning I would like to comment on
the theme of this year's observance
taken from dr. King's last book chaos or
community where do we go from here
the term chaos has more than one meaning
one meeting indeed is particularly
fitting for use at this Institute of
Science and Technology that has to do
with the new science known as chaos
theory which was pioneered by Ed Lorenz
a
sir in our Department of Earth
atmospheric and Planetary Sciences this
new science of chaos deals with
nonlinear and irreversible events best
known of course is the butterfly effect
where a small disturbance becomes
nonlinearly amplified to generate a
major change this means that literally
the beating of a small butterfly's wings
can initiate a change of atmospheric
motions that ultimately become a giant
storm one might say that Martin Luther
King jr. demonstrated this effect in the
social and political realm for if ever
one man's life and one man's life work
changed an entire society or reversibly
it was his but this is the difference
between human and physical environments
unlike the particles that make up our
atmosphere we are not passive we can
participate we can think we can act we
can grow this is what gives us hope
because it is our ability to act with
mutual purpose and to grow together that
will enable us to avoid the usual
meaning of chaos which is the absence of
harmony the state of utter confusion a
total lack of order what we need is
never before as a sense of community a
sense of common purpose the matter of
community is very important to me in my
remarks at the first Martin Luther King
convocation that I attended as MIT as a
member of the MIT community I talked
about celebrating both our individual
differences and our common humanity but
also about refusing to let the
centrifugal forces of intolerance and
injustice pull us apart these are the
forces that can create chaos out of
community they pose a clear and present
danger I understand and I encourage the
different groups within our community to
have and to celebrate a strong sense of
identity and culture but I also sense a
danger in increasingly defining
selves entirely by our racial and ethnic
origin yet Andrew hackers recent book
two Nations makes abundantly clear but
through the kind of hard to the kind of
hard statistical data that we tend to
value at MIT that we black and white are
indeed inhabited two different worlds to
a far greater degree than most of us
would like to admit we must be proud of
who we are interested in where we have
come from and we must celebrate and
understand our differences but this will
all be for naught if we fail to see the
greater glory in our common humanity or
the greater purposes to which we can
apply our varied talents and
perspectives we must build on our
differences but we must build toward a
common purpose
nowhere should community be so important
as in a university where we gather for
the common purpose of learning
despite the frailties and faults of the
society around us we can and must do
better in order to achieve the common
purpose that has brought us here
together in Cambridge during this last
term I visited two classes here at MIT
to talk with students about the culture
and climate of the Institute members of
Professor Mel King's class on peace
justice and planning spoke to me of the
issue of community in a statement that
they had prepared to describe their view
their view of the mission of MIT their
vision of our mission said in part and I
quote MIT is committed to fostering a
community which expresses the variations
and culture of the people of the world
and which is enriched by a dialogue
among the people of our community
leaders in society must be able to
interact on a global level with people
from varied backgrounds leadership in
the global community requires
recognition of our common needs and a
spirit of cooperation of work toward
meeting those needs
surely that vision of these students is
one that we can all share before I
visited
Arobin kill syns class on Black Studies
I was privileged to read several of the
essays that her students had written on
the subject of racism at MIT they were
so interesting and insightful that I
also asked for permission to share them
with the members of our Academic Council
it was of some comfort to me I suppose
to learn that these students find the
same tensions incongruities and
frustrations that I do when trying to
understand and improve the racial
climate on our campus the dozen or so
students whose essays I read clearly
inhabited a dozen or so distinctly
different mi T's in the end I concluded
that the primary difference is among
these students stemmed as much from how
they define themselves and their own
levels of tolerance as from the
definitions bestowed by our community
and the intolerance about them but
clearly we all have a lot of work to do
to greet to reach the vision expressed
by the students in professor Mel King's
class what will it take one thing
obvious but not simple is to see that
the population of MIT represents the
best in creativity and talent from all
segments of our nation and that everyone
has the full opportunity for academic
and career achievement once they are
here let me say flat-out that we have
not done well on the faculty front in
the past several years only 3% of our
faculties are underrepresented
minorities but of the faculty
appointments made last year almost 7%
were members of underrepresented groups
last year was the first year of a new
program to recruit minority and women
faculty to our campus and the provost
and I have been working to see how that
program can be made ever more effective
this fall the task force and minority
administrators pointed out problems in
career advancement noting that fewer
than 100 members of our administrative
staff are underrepresented minorities
that very few are in the highest levels
of Management we are now working to
implement many of the recommendations
from that taskforce which for the first
time systematically analyzed career
patterns of different groups within the
Institute over time on the undergraduate
front we have much more to be pleased
about underrepresented minorities now
comprise 15% of our student body
compared with 8% in 1980 we are
concerned about a drop in this year's
freshman class however and we will be
monitoring the situation carefully
during the coming year at the graduate
level
however we are stuck at the dismal level
of 3% during this entire period although
we had an increase of 50 in the number
of new graduate students of
african-american Hispanic American and
Native American heritage this year this
may not seem like a large number but
when you consider that it is a 21%
increase in a single year it represents
a sea change this dramatic improvement
as a result of aggressive activity on
the part of the office of the Dean of
graduate of the Graduate School with a
lot of help from individual faculty and
students and it is an area which we must
and will continue to emphasize now I
know that numbers are not the whole
story nor are they the answer in and of
themselves but I am trying to keep the
facts in front of us because ultimately
the students that graduate here are the
most important measure of our
effectiveness in improving both the
opportunity for and the quality of
education in this nation it is now my
privilege to introduce today's speaker
William H gray the third if anyone can
speak to the question of how to improve
educational opportunity and experience
in our society it is he like dr. King
mr. gray comes from a family of
ministers and teachers he himself has
been in the ministry for nearly three
decades and has been the pastor of the
5000 member Bright Hope Baptist Church
in Philadelphia for more than 20 years
as was his father
and as was his grandfather before him
but it is alleged as a legislator or an
educator that mr. gray is best known he
was elected to the House of
Representatives in 1978 and became the
first black member of Congress to hold
the position of Majority Whip he left
his mark on our Congress on our country
in many ways he played a key role in
implementing economic sanctions against
South Africa as Budget Committee
chairman for four years he earned a
reputation as a consensus builder
between the White House and the Congress
in budget negotiations and he was an
effective leader an advocate for the
historically black colleges and
universities of this country his support
of education in the position that he
holds today as president and chief
executive officer of the United Negro
College Fund flow naturally from a
family tradition of leadership in
education his father was the president
of two black colleges his mother was a
college dean his grandfather was a
college professor as is his sister
Reverend gray has proved worthy heir to
this legacy not only has he served on
the faculties of several colleges
himself he has since 1991 headed
America's oldest and most successful
fundraising organization on behalf of
African American students I don't have
to tell you that in this that this is a
critical time in history for our black
colleges and universities
african-american high school completion
rates and college enrollment have
reached all-time highs and the challenge
as Reverend gray himself has put it is
to prepare record numbers of African
Americans for successful careers in
every imaginable field to that end the
fund in addition to its traditional
forms of support is establishing an
institute to coordinate research on
issues related to african-american
education at every level from preschool
to graduate study obviously I could go
on regard
his career but I'm sure you've heard
enough from me and are more than ready
to hear from the man who honors us with
his presence today ladies and gentlemen
mr. William H gray the third
- president vest - Barbara Nichols whose
father and I were Boy Scouts together
back in Philadelphia in North
Philadelphia - the faculty and students
and fellow participants here at this MIT
celebration as you come together to
remember a spiritual giant Martin Luther
King jr. I am delighted to join you as
you pause to remember and to reflect
upon where do we go from here
chaos or community when you came into
this auditorium today you saw a film a
film that went back nearly three decades
ago to that great day when over a
quarter of a million Americans gathered
at the lincoln monument to hear the
dreamers dream I was there I was there
standing under a tree because there was
no room around the reflecting pool I was
there
along with all of the others in the
90-degree heat in August as people of
all creeds all colors came together to
protest American apartheid I was there
as I heard Peter Paul and Mary sing the
hymns of the service I was there when
the great Mahalia Jackson gave the
meditation I was there when Martin
Luther King went to the microphone to
speak there was a silence that was
unbelievable considering that we were
outside and there was over a quarter
of a million people and I stood under a
tree almost a quarter of a mile away
from the steps but yet you could hear
the leaves rustling in the wind as
everyone strained to hear the speaker
Martin Luther King for Martin Luther
King symbolized a great movement a
non-violent movement a revolution that
took a country and changed its basic
political social and economic
institutions Martin Luther King
symbolized a movement that was destined
to change this country forever and we
listened as he told us about the
importance of that day now for most of
you you have seen on television many
African Americans speaking to large
crowds you saw Jesse Jackson in 84
running for president addressing the
nation at the Democratic National
Convention you saw him speak on many
occasions you've seen legislators and
mayor's David Dinkins people like Doug
Wilder and yes you even used to see a
guy named bill gray from North
Philadelphia debating fiscal and
economic policy you have grown used to
the fact that you can see people of
color being on center stage but to
understand that moment in 1963 you must
try to remember what America was like
and in order for us to know where do we
go from here in 1993 you have to
understand what 1963 was about for most
of you in this room were not even born
then and Martin Luther King jr. is
simply a celluloid image that you see on
television or
perhaps you read about in a book but let
me tell you about that day and about the
America of that day this was the first
time any African American ever stood on
a national stage and spoke to the entire
nation through the electronic medium
called television this was the first
time that blacks and whites had come
together in many decades to protest
American apartheid for what was America
like it was a country where we had
passed into law apartheid yes America
was a country where blacks could not go
to Duke University even if they could
play basketball blacks could not go to
the University of Alabama even if they
could run the 40-yard dash with a
football uniform on in 4.1 seconds
blacks could not go to Georgia Tech to
get a college degree as a matter of fact
they could not even ride on public
transportation except in those places
reserved for people of color and when
the bus began to fill up and whites got
on the bus the law required that blacks
get up men women and children and give
their seats to those who were white
America then it was not the America you
know today in those days this was not a
phenomenon simply in the South in
Georgia and Mississippi even though that
was the target of the civil rights
movement but oh yes the virtuous North
was not so virtuous here in being
you did not have blacks serving in
capacities that ordinary citizens served
in the police force
the fire department having the
opportunity to elect officials and yes
even in Boston blacks could not live
where they wanted to live even though
they had the money and there was a
ghetto for them it was called Roxburgh I
believe just like it was Harlem in New
York like it was North Philadelphia in
Philadelphia like it was watts in Los
Angeles that was the America of them and
something changed what happened was a
spokesman was found to articulate the
aspiration of those who had been
oppressed simply because of the color of
their skin and there were no voices back
then who were talking about
meritocracies there were no voices back
then who were calling for a level
playing field who now today often quote
Martin back in those days you could not
travel from Boston down to Georgia
without having in Washington DC to move
to the segregated cars of the train in
order to sit there oh no you couldn't
stay in the Sheraton the Hilton or the
Holiday Inn if you were black
that was America but one man came along
simply because a black woman in
Montgomery Alabama decided one day in
the 1950s that she was tired of getting
up and giving her seat to white folk
simply because of the color of their
skin and she refused to get up and they
took her off the bus and locked her up
and mobilized that community to protest
and they looked for a spokesman and
there was a new minister
in town a minister who had come from a
family of ministers a minister who had
come from a family of people who had
fought injustice a father and a mother
who had been successful but who fought
injustice a minister who had gone to a
little black college in Atlanta Georgia
because in those days blacks couldn't go
to most white colleges and even those
that they could go to didn't want too
many of them around and so he went to
Morehouse but he had just graduated and
gotten a PhD up here in Boston and he
was the minister of a historic church
and they said let's go and call on
Reverend King and he became the
spokesman from the Montgomery bus
boycott and from that was formed the
Southern Christian Leadership Conference
and from that became there was a
movement of marching feet of people
sitting in praying and swimming in just
confronting racism and segregation and
apartheid all across this land until
that day in 1963 when they all came
together and by 1965 the walls had come
tumbling down the pattering feet of
Joshua's army had brought down
segregation in America without a shot
being fired without a political
revolution a non-violent movement passed
the civil rights bill of 64 and the
Voting Rights bill because you see
blacks couldn't vote in America just 30
years ago despite the fact that they
served in every war and died for this
country going back to Crispus Attucks
right here in Boston and thus by 1965
the walls had come tumbling down and
then the movement started to change it
was no longer a civil rights movement
changing the law
to allow people to have the rights of
everyone else it moved to an economic
and political rights movement and Martin
Luther King became the spokesperson as
he started organizing across America not
just in the South but also in the north
as he tried to put people together to go
out and vote and also to call for
economic justice most people forget
Martin Luther King jr. was not killed in
a civil rights march oh no he was killed
in an economics rights march he was not
killed fighting simply for black people
oh no he was fighting for fair wages for
all the sanitation workers in that city
in Tennessee and he had taken the cross
from the altar and placed it between two
garbage cans in Memphis calling for a
new economic and political order not
just for black Americans but also for
all Americans and before he died and
before that assassin's bullet killed him
he wrote a book where do we go from here
chaos our community he said our choice
is to go back to polarization conflict
hatred intolerance strife or our choice
is to become a community well it's 30
years laters my brothers and sisters
where are we today first I think Martin
Luther King jr. would say we've come a
mighty long way because today you can
look around and you can see the changes
that are wrought this year as we start a
new administration in Washington DC
there will be 40 members of the
Congressional Black Caucus three of them
coming from the state of Florida three
of them coming from North care
the very places where Martin had called
for a new political order there's a
bright side to the story and when we
look we see people like Doug Wilder who
went to a little black college called
Virginia Union who is now the governor
of the state of Virginia a state that
just 30 years ago would not allow Doug
Wilder to go to the University of
Virginia and now today we can see people
like David Dinkins as the mayor of
America's largest city despite the fact
that African Americans do not make up
the majority of that city we not only
see progress in politics but we also see
it in other fields no one has to tell
you that when you turn on the television
not only do you see people like Michael
Jordan but you also see Oprah Winfrey
who has moved phil donahue right off the
scale and now you can see not only
beyond sports and entertainment but you
see people like reginald lewis who is
the chair of a multi-billion dollar
corporation beatrice and you see people
like Bill Cosby who has become an
entertainment and communication
conglomerate himself and is now talking
about buying NBC we've come a mighty
long way
and yes I know we've come a mighty long
way when I come to MIT and look around
at this audience and at this campus for
you see when I was going to college
there were hardly any of my kind who
were either students or faculty at this
institution and lord help you even got a
gospel choir
we have come a mighty long way and I
think Martin Luther King would say yes
we have made some progress toward a
sense of community but on the other hand
I believe that he would caution us not
to be too optimistic not to assume that
progress will continue and not to assume
that everything is all right here in our
country for you see there's a dark side
we have failed to reach community
there's still chaos in this country
there's still prejudice there's still
racism there's still bigotry there's
still anti-semitism and Martin Luther
King jr. would point that out to you and
it is no longer simply a private matter
for there are those who would have you
believe that yes we know it's around but
it's really a private matter no it is
not for you see it is still embedded in
the structures of our society its
economic structures its political
structures and yes even its educational
structures there is still racism
anti-semitism and bigotry in our society
and let me share with you those things
that people like to forget about the
fact is last year that the Census
Department and the Labor Department's
reports point out that in 1992 the
average black family median income is
still only 57 percent of white family me
and income in America exactly where it
was in 1968 Martin would say we haven't
made progress yet and when you look at
the infant mortality rates that exist in
some of our inner-city and rural areas
for poor children white and black and
and that we can cure that problem very
simply but yet we won't model would say
we still have not made progress yet and
when you look at the fact that even
today though we predominate the
basketball court the football field
whether it is the bills or the Boston
Celtics we still haven't gotten into the
front office or the coaching ranks of
those sports we still have a long way to
go and yes even though we've got Bill
Cosby Oprah Winfrey and all of those
shows on television that are popular and
making money and symbolize the problems
the frailties of All American families
the fact is that we still haven't gotten
into the boardrooms of entertainment and
communications or at the executive level
and yes Martin would say we still have a
long way to go for despite the fact that
we will see in a new administration a
lot of women the reality is that women
of all color black white brown Asian
American Latinos still do not have equal
opportunity with white males in American
society we still have a long way to go
and Martin would laugh at those who use
his name and his quotations incorrectly
those who stand up and say didn't Martin
Luther King jr. say that one day he
wanted to see his children sitting at
the table with other children of other
color other races and they would be
judged on the content of their character
and not on the color of their skin and
didn't he mean by that that we should
get rid of any attempts to redress
nearly 400 years of legalized
apartheid in this nation and only 25
years of some progress and therefore
they use Martin's words to call for the
elimination of affirmative efforts to
integrate faculties staffs and diversify
student bodies and saying we want a
meritocracy and people ought to be
judged on the content of their character
that's what Martin was talking about
wasn't he it is insulting degrading and
downright wrong Martin talked about that
as a task at logical hope not a reality
that could be reached in 25 years you
don't level the playing field in 25
years for minorities and women after 400
years of legalized slavery and D human a
ssin and then say everybody is equal
oh no we won't reach community if we
fail to understand what he stood for and
we've seen people today retreating some
of them even marched with us down there
in Washington
I've seen people suddenly as they are
worried about competition from those
women and minorities who now enter the
workforce begin to say we've gone too
far with this affirmative action stuff
we've gone too far
allowing these minority students to come
in and I have seen professors and
faculty members I know y'all not gonna
invite me back no mo
whoo 25 years ago were in the forefront
of the movement for progressive
government and opening up the system now
begin to question the capabilities and
the qualities of those minorities that
we are allowing to come to our great
University my Hispanic brother talked
about how in his experience today and I
hope you heard him
that professors look at him and say you
don't belong here
you got here on a special program well
brother Morales don't feel bad I
remember when I went to my college you
know there were five of us in the whole
place and I remember after being
accepted and going to look over the
campus with my father and I I was fairly
successful I was the only four letter
athlete in my high school I was fourth
in a class of 369 I had a 3.75 grade
point average in high school and my SAT
scores were pretty good and I remember
the Dean of admission sitting there I
had already been accepted looking at me
and saying to my father I really don't
think he ought to come here because
he'll never graduate and I'll never
forget four years later or when we had
the honors banquet God is not mocked you
do reap what you sow and to put it in
another turn as we said in all
Philadelphia what goes around cometh
around it just so happened that as I sat
at that banquet prepared to receive the
highest award given to a history major
and every senior class guess who was
sitting right next to me
the same man who had told me four years
ago that I had no business at that
institution
well my father looked at him and said
ain't you to do who said we have become
confused and we have lost sight of what
the struggle for the Beloved Community
is the struggle for the Beloved
Community is to open the doorway wider
the struggle for the Beloved Community
is to build bridges so that those who
have been historically disadvantaged
will have an opportunity to catch up and
thus those who argue today that the
playing field is level those who quote
Martin Luther King about the content of
their character and the color of their
skin I have one question to ask you and
that is simply this are all American
women of all colors standing on the same
level playing field with white males in
America I think you know the answer to
that and the answer's hell no
we've made progress but don't take a few
token Dean's a few token professors are
too a few token achievements and
entertainment and yes even in politics
and then conclude that we've struggled
long enough yes we've come a long way
but we still have a even longer way to
go in our society to have community and
avoid the chaos that we see on some of
our college campuses and some of our
communities like in New York with Crown
Heights finally there's one other thing
when you talk about where do we go from
here you not only have to know the truth
of where we came from and my brothers
and sisters there are some people who
are trying to Reve tell the story about
the past revisionists I think they are
called
in academia who want to act like things
were not that bad they were bad so don't
let anybody tell you let's go back to
the good old days
number one they weren't good and they
weren't oh they were you know not that
old they were young but the question
becomes if we are in a moment of our
history where we've made progress since
Martin's book and since thirty years ago
when he gave the speech what must we do
now to continue to move toward building
community I will tell you that it is
more imperative today than ever before
and let me tell you why it has nothing
to do with good feelings it has nothing
to do with humanitarian moralistic
motives in a real sense the desire to
build community today is a much greater
imperative than ever before and the
reason is that there's a revolution
going on in America and most of you are
not even aware of it no it's not the
global revolution geopolitical where you
see the walls come tumbling down
the you know Berlin Wall and and the
breakup of the Soviet Union and the
ethnic centrifugal forces of
self-determination redrawing the map of
Europe or Nelson Mandela being free in
South Africa that's not it and it's not
even the global economic competitive
revolution where we've got competition
in the Pacific Rim and in Europe no
there is another revolution
let me quickly describe it for you
because it is an economic imperative for
all of our interests to move toward
community and opportunity for all God's
children I saw it the other day when I
got on an airplane I got armed and I'm
fascinated by planes and they had the
door open and I looked in and I saw the
captain here hanging all down the neck
and I said what happened to rules and
regulations what happened to values and
then the captain turned around she was a
blonde
and then I looked over and I saw the
first officer and he was a brother as it
Oh Lord then I looked at the flight
engineer and he was an Asian American
and about that time someone tapped me on
the shoulder the head flight attendant
to tell me I was blocking traffic and I
turned around and there was huaynito
Rodriquez telling me to go sit down
as it all Lord I'm in trouble today
but let me tell you that was the best
flight I have ever had in my life they
flew that plane and landed it
magnificently but that experience
symbolizes at a revolution that is going
on right now that is creating a an
economic imperative for the Beloved
Community and it's simply this that in
the next century 85% of all the new
workers in America are going to be women
minorities and new immigrants and that
means that all of us are increasingly
going to have to depend upon the
productivity the skills the excellence
of those today that we call
disadvantaged so it is in our own
self-interest to move toward a community
of equal opportunity or else the
prosperity the strength and the growth
of this nation will decline why because
these are the people who are going to be
America's future and so we must move
toward community and in order to move
toward community there's something that
you and I can do there are four things
that I suggest that Martin would want us
to do first we have to achieve
excellence don't sit around here at MIT
sucking your militant thumb because you
find out there may be some residues of
racism at this university what did you
expect
there's no difference between the people
here and the people out there is just
the people out there are working inside
here or coming here to go to school
understand that you are here to achieve
excellence and to assimilate all the
knowledge traditions and information so
that you can move forward and build a
new world order Martin Luther King was a
strong believer in educational
excellence that's why he had a PhD he
had a Masters of Divinity and a Bachelor
of Arts degree as well and you if you
are to be catalyst for change if you are
to build the Beloved Community I don't
care what color you are I don't care
what sex you are I don't care where you
come from you have got to achieve
educational excellence so don't get mad
and sit around because you find some
problems you ever see Michael Jordan say
timeout and walk over to the side and
say coach every time I get the ball
there are five people trying to stop my
stuff you ever see that you ever see
what's that brother here with the Boston
Celtics Lewis your leap all over the
play you ever see them say timeout and
go over to coach and say every time I
get the ball somebody trying to stop my
stuff you ever see Robert Parish do that
no why because they know that the moment
they get on that field the moment they
get on that court that's the name of the
game somebody's out there to stop your
stuff so therefore understand that you
will never achieve success by sitting
around crying about the problem run
faster jump higher and shoot straighter
than anybody else
and then you too will be able maybe to
sit at the honors ban quit and look the
director of admissions in the eye and as
they aren't you to do to Tomi secondly
also remember something else you are put
on this universe on the Starship called
earth not just to take care of you or
yours you are put here to be of service
to your community and to the human human
community so if all you do is achieve
excellence and then go out and make as
much as you can can as much as you can
and then sit on your can your name is
swine but if you go out in life make as
much as you can can as much as you can
and give back as much as you can then
you will be called blessed the reason
why we remember Martin Luther King jr.
today is because he didn't sit on his
PhD from Boston University
he didn't sit on his master's in
divinity from Crozer Theological
Seminary
he didn't sit on his MA bachelor's
degree for Morehouse just make money but
he decided to do something for a larger
cause for a larger purpose you too must
be willing to give service and then
thirdly you must have within you a sense
of brotherhood and sisterhood that
overcomes intolerance bigotry
anti-semitism prejudice of all kind and
sexism why because they are all sides of
the same coin and my brothers and
sisters sure folks gonna make you mad
there are going to be people in other
communities who will not understand your
struggle there will be people who will
make you awfully angry but if we're
going to build the community that is
beloved we must begin the revolution
within ourselves
of loving one another tolerating one
another and yes even when other folks
and other communities hurt us tried to
sensitize them and bring them to a new
position not by violent means or by
hating them in return but by showing
them that we are better and we know a
better way let me tell you what I'm
talking about
I remember one event that will always be
framed in my mind about Martin King for
you see not only was I there in 1963 but
the King family in the gray family has
been friends for three generations
I used to preach at Ebenezer Baptist
Church on many occasions so did my
father and when Martin Luther King jr.
went to Crozer Theological Seminary in
Chester Pennsylvania he often used to
come to our home for meals on the
weekend and to practice preaching at the
brighto Baptist Church where I am now
the pastor and I knew Martin first as a
young man who was in seminary and not as
a Nobel Prize winner and I suppose when
someone you know ends up being great a
superstar you know it's a hard gap but I
will never forget one thing that it
happened that proves something to me
about Brotherhood sisterhood tolerance
and love of humanity Martin Luther King
jr. was nearly killed
in New York he was stabbed by a woman
with a knife that went so deep into his
chest
they had to take him to the hospital
with his still sticking out to perform
the surgery to remove it because it was
so close to his heart and I'll never
forget that when Martin recuperated and
got well and went back to the South he
decided that he couldn't stay in the
south but he had to come north and raise
money he came to our home in
Philadelphia because he didn't have the
money to stay in hotels the movement was
too poor and so he stayed with the Grays
at 1511 North 16th Street for a week as
he tried to raise money in Philadelphia
and I'll never forget that every
morning and every evening he would have
to put ice on this terrible scar that
was still raw on his chest and of course
all of us would start to talk about the
woman you know she was no good we
started calling her names and all of
that and I'll never forget to this day
that Mardin stopped us cold in our
tracks and said don't talk about her
that way no matter what she did and no
matter who she is she's a child of God
and from that moment on none of us
talked about the woman that nearly
killed him for the rest of the week even
though he obviously was in pain as he
would put ice on this raw scar tissue
you see Martin understood that we are
all part of a network of mutuality we
are all brothers and sisters regardless
of the color of our skin regardless of
where we live regardless of where we
come from and it behooves all of us to
try to help the rest of us if we're
going to have a beloved community and so
my brothers and sisters I urge you to
have a sense of tolerance a sense of
sensitivity and create a new spirit of
brotherhood and sisterhood within you
because the revolution starts inside of
you and then finally the last thing if
we want to move from chaos to community
is we must never rest in the fight for
justice and we must understand that
injustice is often subtle and that we
must stand up against injustice wherever
it is found we must say to our political
systems that if you they are in just
they must correct themselves and I've
got to tell you as one who has been in
that system there are problems that we
have yet to address for you see I can't
understand a nation that is willing to
say give me your tired your poor if you
come from Europe if you are a refugee
from Europe but yet if you are Haitian
we have a concentration camp for you I
don't understand that I don't understand
a nation that says if you're from
Yugoslavia and the conflict there come
on to America if you're from Poland come
on to America give me your tired your
poor but if you're from black Africa
trying to escape the warfare of Somalia
Ethiopia I'm sorry we can't let you in
there still injustice in our society and
it is incumbent upon all of us to be
vigilant and to continue the struggle
and so don't just come here today and
remember a dreamer a historical figure
of the past but go from this place
committed to excellence go from this
place committed to serve your community
and your world go from this place
being more tolerant and creating a
sisterhood and Brotherhood of all people
of all colors in our backgrounds and go
from this place committed that you to
like Martin Luther King we'll struggle
against injustice and who knows one
person standing up to the Goliath of
poverty of militarism racism and sexism
may be able to bring the walls down as
he did it's not gonna be easy
it never is easy and it won't be any
easier for this generation than it was
for mine but let me tell you in closing
for those of you who are prepared to
struggle something I learned long time
ago which has led in my life and giving
me direction and strength
it happened in Baton Rouge Louisiana
where grandma lived we used to go visit
her every summer and I'll never forget
that day I found out about racism still
I saw a water fountain I went over to
get a drink and just as I started to
drink a hand grabbed me and said
you can't drink
from that fountain go to the one over
there for you and on the other side of
the department store was another
fountain with a big sign that said
colored only well the water looked the
same to me
but anyway my sister grabbed me and took
me home to Grandma and my grandmother
was a school teacher and she immediately
was confronted I guess with the problem
that all black mothers and parents have
to face that day when their child finds
out that there's something different she
was faced with the same problem that all
Latino mothers and fathers must be faced
with when they have to tell their
children that there are people who
disliked them simply because of their
origin I guess she had to face that same
day that the Irish mother faced in the
1890s here in Massachusetts when their
child went out and saw the signs Nina no
Irish need apply but she took me out to
the University called the front porch
sat me down in the classroom called the
big swing and she began to tell me about
America about what America was but she
also had a way of taking a negative and
turning into a positive and talked to me
about the could B's of life for you see
it's not enough to dwell in the past
it's not enough to dwell in the reality
of this moment but life belongs to those
who are always looking at the could be
of life and who are willing to create it
and I'll never forget she said to me son
you see that mayor the City Council the
state legislature the governor the
Congress the courts it takes all of them
to keep you from drinking at that water
family that's how important you are
and she told me then that life was never
going to be a bed of roses and that I
would have difficulty and that
difficulty would be put there by other
people regardless of what I did but my
job was to climb the mountain and to
overcome the difficulty and I'm so glad
she did because you see that little boy
born in Baton Rouge Louisiana who later
on went to school in Philadelphia and
North Philadelphia grew up to be not
only a minister not only a college
professor but in the 1980s he used to
sit on the second floor of the White
House and looked the most powerful man
in the eye
the president of America Ronald Reagan
and say no
and I have learned that the only way you
get there is by remembering what she
closed the lecture with she closed with
some words that I didn't understand then
and I didn't know where she got them
from but I understand now because they
were the words of another black mother
to her son and they are the words that I
leave with you here at this community of
learning I leave it to all of you who
are so journeying through this place
whether you're black or white no matter
where you come from for indeed the
struggle against injustice is a constant
one and she told me these words well son
life for me ain't been no crystal stairs
it's had tacks splinters boards bare
places where there ain't been no carpet
but all the time
iseman a climbing reaching landings
turning corners and going in the dark
where there ain't been no light so son
don't you sit on them they're stairs
cuz you find it kind of hard for life
for me ain't been no crystal stairs and
eyes still a climbing my brothers and
sisters as we celebrate this day and
remembering a spiritual giant that God
gave to us and who sojourned and changed
our land we must remember that we to a
call to climb the stairs and I urge you
here to reach new landings to turn new
corners and for God's sake go into the
dog where they ain't been no light
[Applause]
I would like to thank Reverend gray for
addressing the MIT community and
answering the question where do we go
from here I was very excited to have
Reverend gay
excuse me gray come and speak to us
today I'm very proud that a fellow
Philadelphian has accomplished so much
for people at home and abroad
my father Melvin Russell Nichols and
Reverend Gregory Boy Scouts together and
my father tells stories about the greys
in the times they had a Bright Hope
Baptist Church the same pride my father
feels when he tells these stories is the
same pride that I feel right now once
again thank you
[Applause]
at this time in the celebration I would
like to invite my peers in the MIT
gospel choir to perform
[Music]
speak to by our Lord give me your holy
word if I can't hear from you
then I know what to do
I've never gone my own just such a
spirit guide and the two by
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
the MIT community is full of rich talent
now Linda Lipsy shoes from the graduate
school office will perform for us she
will be accompanied by pianos
[Music]
now I will ask Reverend paradise to give
the benediction and afterwards I will
return to state a few announcements and
close the ceremony let us pray
Oh God let the words that have been
spoken let the music we have heard that
the lives that have been witnessed to
hear today
sink into our hearts cease our
imaginations galvanize our wills and
change us amen
once again I would like to thank our
keynote speaker Reverend William gray
for coming to MIT today and giving us a
new perspective there will be
there'll be reception immediately
following this program in 22news that's
in the third floor of the Stratton
Student Center we encourage you to
attend dr. King's book where do we go
from here
chaos our community will be on we'll be
on sale outside in the lobby of Kresge
Auditorium finally if you view your
program you'll see that there are many
events taking place this weekend the
first is the conference revolution the
untold story sponsored by the MIT
community fellows then on saturday night
journey into a dream a tribute to dr.
Martin Luther King will be performed by
Samina McCord and associates this
concludes the 19th annual Martin Luther
King memorial celebration thank you for
celebrating with us
[Applause]